Olá a todos pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dar que estejam muito bem menos é mais
Olha o estrago saques Novos Produtos
mais estranhos que eu consegui encontrar
no lixo aquela loja chinesa possa se
conhecem né eles que mais pessoal eu
peço desculpa porque eu estou aqui a
imprimir uma impressão 3D Então eu não
sei se o som vai atrapalhar aqui no
vídeo qualquer forma aliás será impressa
uma coisa para vocês aqui mas bora lá
pessoal vamos demais já deixei o meu
celular é que aqui neste vídeo uma
partilhem com os vossos amigos lá no
WhatsApp é muito importante isso ok Bora
lá então ver pessoal às nove coisas que
eu comprei que não vixe meu eu vi muita
coisa bizarra Ultimamente eu vou até ver
aqui olha lá então pessoal sem Muita
enrolação a primeira coisa que eu
encontrei aqui no lixo muito estranho
Olha só Finger é Mercedes de mão mas
basicamente pessoal não encontrei aqui
mãos que cabem nos dedos e simulam mãos
ou seja nós ficamos com 165 Vera 155 e
eu encomendei Pessoal este produto Vamos
lá ver como é que Steven na vida real
Olha o que chegou meu vieram muitas mãos
estas mãos custam três euros eu
a banda esta versão porque eu acho que
os três euros é só um conjunto de 2
então provavelmente foi cinco euros que
eu comprei mais ok nós vamos lá dentro
só é que estão as nossas mãos que eu
quero abrir este ver como é que fica bem
e foi abalada até está cheia também não
falar e usam bem sujo aqui dentro tá
sujo já vem sujo olha aqui olha aí OK
mas vamos testar pessoal eu vou abrir
aqui todas as
é uma duas três quatro cinco seis sete
oito que está atrás dois números
inteiros é isso mas já deixa o seu like
aqui nesse vídeo pessoal você que vocês
adoram esses vídeos dele e eu realmente
encomenda as coisas ok pessoal mas como
nós estamos sempre via nós temos assim é
um problema Mundial e as encomendas
demoram muito a chegar até que eu pensei
eu pensei em fazer esse tipo de vídeo
também mas a mostrar Muitas das coisas
que ninguém tem acesso a poucas pessoas
têm excesso então lixo a muito produto
tipo as pessoas não conseguem encontrar
que são produtos assim mas muito
estranho sem normalmente a lixo não
recomendo então vocês gostariam que eu
fizesse algum tipo de vídeo eu mostrar
os produtos sem Tecnicamente comprar né
mas tipo só mostrar se quiserem comenta
embaixo só a muito duas lá fora que
fazem isso mas eu não sei se vocês iriam
gostar de ver só a loja não comprar o
produto realmente mas enfim acaba vocês
pessoal comentem aí embaixo e Bora lá
então testar as nossas mãozinhas Ok vou
colocar aqui daí eu tenho aqui a segunda
câmera mas fica muito estranho é muito a
cor não tem nada a ver isto é bem cor
laranja What irmão do Donald trump O Meu
Deus será que vai Será que vai ser
Olá eu sou habilidoso só falta apurar
agora tu não tem o em qualquer coisa
aqui dentro de uma coisa aqui dentro em
qualquer coisa atraiu é isso O que é
isto eu vi restos de borracha dentro da
mão para vocês vão construíram bem estou
chinês ai dói o Polegar dói olha aí
encolheu o meu polegar Isto é perigoso
só não não encomendei Isto é que estão
pessoal as nossas mãos não sei porque é
que eu encomendei isso não eu tenho a
cabeça porque foi aqui para o Miguel que
eles como é que eu vou usar isso no tipo
no dia a dia não dá que isso não é
prático isso não dá para nada ok pessoal
esse foi o primeiro produto bizarro
comenta embaixo também onde é que vocês
acham que foi mais bizarro aqui é
próximo o produto bizarro que custou
nove e noventa euros Ok eu sei que muita
gente está deste vídeo é do Brasil
portanto Isto vai estar convertido em
reais mas enfim não haver aos 90 pessoal
e eu encomendei um boneco de peluche do
aí olhando um Toy algodão soft está
extraterrestre recomendadas pelos
pessoal eu acho que escolhi o tamanho
médio aquele tem aqui o mais pequeno
é um grande eu não arrisquei o grande
porque eu acho que ia pagar muito mais
caro e pode ser que ficasse lá na
alfândega ou qualquer coisa assim então
para não arriscar a encomenda e o médio
ó esse chegou a casa aqui ao nosso
bairro lembro da isso não é muito
estranho Olha o azul Ok eu acho que a
minha namorada porque ela já andou aqui
ver as minhas encomendas e ela gostou
muito dele então acho que vou oferecer
umas Olha a cara dele é muito estranha
meu é uma das coisas mais bizarras que
existem O que é que alguém encomendar um
peluche de um ele e nem que era um ele
neste meu é estranho eu não sei que eu
tenho 400 aqui uma das coisas estranhas
dois esses era o produto pessoal nós
recebemos aqui em casa me sapo triste
verde para namorada desde que eu deveria
oferecer mas não isso vai ficar para mim
só porque eu tenho problemas à noite
então tenho pinto colocar aqui esta
vendinha no olho eu não sei qual é olha
dá para deixar o olho foi por isso que
eu encomendei eu tenho certeza agora lá
pessoal vamos ver se eu recebi
geralmente esta encomenda tá aqui
encontrei este né
Como é que está a pessoal a nossa venda
tu sabe Ok vamos ver como é que estão os
olhos Ok está aqui o que o produto
promete uma fita com alho sabe é que
sabem que muitas vezes o que vem ali na
imagem não é o que chega realmente acaso
Ok já vem rasgado aqui dentro que serve
percof a Isto é percebido que não vou
mais nada Talvez esteja para por aqui
uma Paula tipo mais dura um cartão mas
não está pessoal
a brincar na minha cabeça eu acabei de
tomar banho cabelo tá tudo molhado mas
enfim
E aí está apertado Vocês conseguem ver
alguma coisa eu não vou abrir os olhos
Agora sim já consegui ver agora sim tô
de olho tô de olho só o que é que acha
um bom produto ou não daqui custo quanto
foi em de euros Ok dois euros foi bem
barato ele pode melhorar a vossa noite
de sono Ok pode melhorar eu vou tentar
hoje a noite assim então daqueles
produtos que até melhor quando vocês vão
maquiagem e sim dentro do avião e tudo
mais e isso serve mas eu acho para estar
em casa é bem poder até a próxima Bora
lá pessoal o próximo produto desta
desses também é um peluche Ok eu
encomendei 3D bigfix Olha aí tem escamas
de verdade tinha três tamanhos eu acho
que encomendei o médio também grande é
muito grande Olha aí é do tamanho da
mulher é muito grande é isso meu eu só
encomendei o médio eu acho aqui está
pessoal da ver com o rabo de fora meu
deus o que que alguém haveria de comprar
um peixe na lixo Só se vocês quiserem
oferecer uma prenda bem poder a vossa
mãe no natal está aqui
E aí memo algodão aqui dentro ok pessoal
tá aqui o nosso país não é bonito do
fofo com estranho
o OK mas desde que estou quanto oito
euros oito eu não acredito paguei 8:00
por isso enfim pessoal tá aqui o nosso
peixe Deluxe uma das coisas bizarras que
eles têm Bora lá continuar Ainda temos
aqui muita coisa assim que nós temos
mais coisas aqui a ver com peixes Ok
portanto fiquem atentos é só até o fim
do vídeo ainda tá aqui produto muito
bizarro vamos lá próximo com este daqui
meu este daqui eu acho que foi um dos
primeiros da minha seleção quando fiz
aqui a minha lista dele eu vejo ao só
pessoal eu encomendei uma bolsa barriga
de ser humano alguma bolsa que simula a
barriga daqui várias tem a do Alan tem
de rico do Magno eu acho que acabei por
encomendar é esta normal e que uma cobre
mais não mas como podem ver ele está a
conduzir e simula muito bem que ele está
com a barriga de fora não é tanta é só
uma boa ok pessoal mas bora lá bonitão
que é que chegou a casa estão bem custou
oito euros caro para uma bolsa atacar
mas vamos ver o que é que ligou aqui tá
nossa encomenda pessoal bora lá abrir
o ok material vez que é bom aqui a
barriga com pelo é umbigo Às vezes aqui
a parte de dentro é boa também tem
aqueles isolamentos térmicos sabem
também é fixe vou ver se o Face funciona
mesmo que isto eu vou usar o
Olá pessoal eu não sei se isso vai caber
na minha barriga não é pois como vocês
sabem o seu tamanho xxxl ou que é
pessoal poderá experimentar eu não sei
se estava em mim mas Tecnicamente isso
vai ficar assim ó como é que eu uso Isto
é um bocado porque eu não consigo usar
não consigo usar pessoal eu fiquei
triste agora só mas vale a pena eu
quando emagrecer eu vou usar certamente
esta bolsa está aqui é uma qualidade até
boa vale os oito euros Afinal oque é
louca é louca eu vou fazer produto
bizarro ou não é pessoal comentem isso
não é bizarro é fiz aqui também é um dos
mais bizarros Ok eu encomendei
basicamente é um guarda-chuva para a
cabeça para quem não tenho paciência de
de andar com o guarda-chuva tipo na mão
vocês aqui tem a oportunidade de colocar
na cabeça e essa podem formar corporal e
tu disse o mar a vossa vida mas enfim
isso é um guarda-chuva provas meterem na
cabeça Ok mas bora lá ver pessoal se
chegou a casa ou não está aqui chegou
assim
e como é que isto se o meu a minha
cabeça não primeiro lugar a minha cabeça
não cabe aqui acho que ela acaba aqui é
impossível Olha esse cabeção de Pop
Figure preço um samurai do free Fire
Olha lá meu ninguém tem isto ninguém usa
isto eram a moda meu ascendente amor ok
é resistente eu duvido que alguma gota
de chuva caia como sei lá assim né E só
custou um e 79
e agora lá pessoal próximo produtos
também os produtos bizarros basicamente
é uma t-shirt de corpo de homem Pois é
que eu não preciso porque eu sou
realmente o homem é que nós temos
músculos coisas que o coisa que eu não
tenho o resto aqui do it disso é suposto
simular um ser humano de verdade alguém
Ninguém tem a costa assim eu garanto
vocês tiverem Costa assim Manda uma
imagem lá para o meu Instagram ou quem
vídeo que vocês não gostar assim ó mas
enfim pessoal eu acho que encomendei um
genérico acho que encomendei o primeiro
bom mas bora lá ver pessoal que é que
chegou a casa realmente pense formato ou
não é que está a pessoal aqui está a
nossa de Cheiro aí bora lá ver o que é
que vem dentro isso
eu não encomendei em 2xl não em 6x ela
85 euros e eu encomendei 6xl eu acho
porque como vocês sabem o tamanho chinês
é um pouco superior ao nosso um pouco
inferior a tag xxl daqui equivale a 100
XL de lá então eu encomendei assim que
era para ter a certeza que me carioca é
que eu acho que vai servir acho que dá
para mim era bem pessoal eu vou eu vou
ali me vestir e já volto
E aí pessoal Olha só meu peitoral até
parece que não treinei hoje né olha Tubo
fadão o guru agora
o pessoal vir é muito fácil para
assistirem músculos nesta quarentena é
só comprar em que uma t-shirt de cinco
euros já foi tava a sua vida pessoal eu
vou continuar o resto do vídeo com esta
t-shirt está super engraçado
se for uma pessoa o próximo e este eu
achei bem bizarro Talvez o mais bizarro
de todos porque eu aqui tenho uma
costura eu eu acho que é o monstro a
Kids Boys ter atrás que é o Astro inglês
ou mas como podem ver pela imagem bem
como Pérolas Preciosas aquela Pérola
grande Tá Sabe aquela pedra o pirata
tira da outra 9:30 ver que é verdadeira
eu acho que eles fazem isso as moedas
mas da com outra também é filme pessoal
bem outra colorida pode vir uma outra
pressiona aqui dentro elas garantem isso
olha aí mostra aberta Olha isso Será que
tem uma outra aqui dentro do meu Olha o
também pode ainda mostra que vem cá para
casa que é porque eu já abri olha o
tamanho da outra que vem olha isso ok
pessoal mas vamos ver o que é que tem
aqui dentro e Talvez possa ter uma uma
pérola qualquer coisa assim Isso deve
ser falso né Por nada pérolas assim
coloridas meu pode ir em precisa de
espermas aqui dentro Okay Será que tem
aquela água aqui dentro que a água
salgava isto cheira a Mar mesmo
se não estiver a mesma marca só eu não
estou brincar cheiro água do mar vem no
vácuo aqui olha aí eu vou vir aqui do
Sol
E ai tô comendo partir a unha vem com
essa é uma das coisas mais bizarras
vocês tem que ir a casca mesmo agora vai
partiu partiu ali já quebrou a pessoal
eu vou a fera fera fera fera Costa
actual um bisturi cirúrgico e
o tempero lá mesmo tem pérola a solto
sem pérolas Olha isso
e cheira a Mar plasticina a mistura do
chá depois disso Neymar por aí tem mais
pérolas aqui olha aí como ela chegou
nojento pessoal esta é uma das coisas
mais bizarras que eu stem com certeza
como esta tem muitas mais pessoal é por
isso que eu vou pedir aquele vídeo que
se quiserem eu vejo esse tipo de
produtos sem encomendar não é porque
assim revemos a para vocês fizerem
vídeos desses em documento aí porque
tenho muita coisa deste gênero lá tem
uma pedra assim meio azulado feio é mais
aqui umas Pérola outra Azul tipo Céu
Azul um merda que falar pessoa outro e o
produto no no produto Este é o
carro-chefe aqui das coisas mais
bizarras Se bem que eu achei esse aqui
já bem bizarro Mas enfim pessoal nós
temos aqui ver é uma moda criativa peixe
realista do meu basicamente isso são
chinelos de peixe Havaianas aquela
típica baiana Mas isso não é a baiana é
mesmo chinelo a havaiana aquela coisa no
meio do dedo né aqui não aqui é chinelo
do peixe ele está tudo
e do Lidl aqui eu vou usar o chinelo da
real moda Dark frame para lançar a moda
em Portugal só Recebemos um peixe Nemo
peixe novinho vento porque ele foi 9/90
meu espero que isso tem uma qualidade
boa pelo cheiro muito mal mesmo Olha
pelo menos está muito parecido com a
imagem Alô que atua ver aqui dente que
está muito parecido o material também é
muito bom ok meu tá incrível sério por 9
mente a escola a pena agora só resta
outro estado encomendei a uma tamanho 45
da Europa e
e bora lá ver se funciona se funciona
não se cabe no meu pé é
e entrou de volta
é só tá aqui agora é aquele cheira
queijo né perfeito Pessoal este chinelo
meu e aqui estão os Novos Produtos mais
bizarros da eu espero que vocês tenham
gostado aqui deste vídeo pessoal já
sabem se quiserem que eu Encomendo mais
coisas deste tipo comenta embaixo não se
importarem que eu faço vídeos só é ver
os produtos não existissem encomendar
necessariamente tipo na hora não é mas
tem também pessoal que vocês gostarem
deste tipo de conteúdo eu começo também
a dar umas rede usam os produtos aqui e
é tudo pessoal já sabem deixa o like
aqui neste vídeo compartilhem com ondas
vossos amigos é isso pessoal fiquem bem
e até a próxima um